you know we're gonna do a straight count
on this right now counting the counter
yes good idea you should probably do it
fast so we don't make our friends here
wait okay 20.
40. 60. 80 100
20 40. 60 80 200. you know what I'm fast
okay I'll take care of that one two
three four five six seven eight nine one
two three four five six seven eight nine
one two three four five six seven eight
nine while you're doing piles and nine
it's faster than tens oh really I do my
nines ten times and then do an extra
pile of 10 in here fast okay yeah yeah
you know we should probably both be
counting oh well let's just get two with
this double trouble all right and 24
[Music]
I'm sorry can you could you please could
you do something like over there please
oh you know what what's that I got it we
could time me okay we time me counting
out a thousand